don't lock that triangle this is the guy
guys who just attacked a Muslim sister I
give Salam too much evil in Bangladesh
Salam to the people of Marrakech
somewhat akin what have already better
care to bloggers and citizen dear
friends and attackers up and I don't
know if you guys have heard about it
I've seen the footage I'm about to play
the footage tuned inshallah this is a
man who allegedly attacked a sister now
after this incident after you watch the
video after this incident he has been
saying that he's a Muslim he has been
saying that he slipped and was holding
on to this Muslim sister and there's a
misunderstanding we're gonna come and
talk about this and we're gonna talk
about that I witnessed a person who was
actually there who saw it for himself
and hear what he had to say but let's
watch it first in Sala post one look at
one go this is the guy guys who just
attacked a Muslim sister in Ward and
pour the peace on their way to China
he's trying to get away yeah this
brothers mashallah hunt me you're gonna
hide your face after hitting a Muslim
sister and you're not gonna go nowhere
we understand we will not allow any
woman to be attacked in our areas
retained you not resisting I'm a smash
if you resist we would be you we will
have to use reasonable force to keep you
from a break and Felicia on their way
smashes okay stay still stay still
please brothers make sure all the
sisters all the women are safe in our
areas we need to protect them from
tricks like this you put this message I
know woman no matter what color what
religion she is we will not tolerate
being attacked
so I'm one-eighth oh this can happen to
you it's gonna happen to anyone just
come happen to any of our sisters any of
our brothers and sadly these cowards
tend to attempt females you know they
always talk about you know Muslim women
are oppressed or pressed or press I know
we'll save them by oppressing them
further yeah apparently they were pushed
yeah now we can see brothers and sisters
this is the
impact that the far-right are having on
our streets and this is the same impact
in a negative impact Isis and certain
individuals with crazy mindsets are
having they preach hate innocent people
die in it non-muslims the far-right
preach hate and the same thing happening
on our streets who's suffering we're
suffering were the ones who are
suffering at their hands a brainwashed
individual most likely 100 percent I
would have no doubt this man has been
watching Britain first Tommy Robinson
and his likes in order for us to stop
these brothers and sisters we need to
carry on educating these people we need
to educate these people we need to tell
them the true message of Islam and Hum
them in love by city halls and
organizations Salaam Studios we are
doing that and you have helped us and we
are carrying doing our work and I'm
doing this video to highlight this issue
and do not let it go under the carpet
because the more it goes under the
carpet the more it starts to smell that
is the reason why such people like Tommy
Robinson and his legs have to be locked
up Anjem Choudary appreciate and rightly
so he got locked up this is the reason
why we are so stunned towards the far
right and certain individuals like Anjem
Choudary and his followers because it's
at their hands that these people are
getting brainwashed sadly so this was
just was a video let's hear the
eyewitness take on the matter if this
guy was really a Muslim or if not
inshallah so this little clips I'm
playing from the braava himself of what
he saw and what happened so now whatever
brothers our sisters my name is sheriff
Hussein I'm from Birmingham all of you
guys must have seen the video that's
well quite frankly has gone viral today
regarding an individual who was
restrained and detained under citizen's
arrest regarding a attack on a Muslim
sister this guy I want you to say since
this videos come out we've had local
community members men including women
that have come forward and actually I've
stated
that this isn't a one-off incident
that's happened this individual has
followed one of my neighbors she lives
for five girls away from him he's
followed her a few times of the wash
wreath road until she gets home many
males in the community have told this
individual to stay away they are a lot
of people that I've been commenting it
could be just or maybe somebody's very
wrong I I read us this myself so what
I'm trying to say is what really dug
today we did nothing wrong
we are here to protect our community no
matter if you're white you're black your
brain Hindu Muslim Sikh Christian Jews
whoever you are
it does not matter our duty as men is to
protect our community have protect our
women
that's what message and I just want to
thank everybody for the really nice
messages but all I want to say in my
eyes this is nothing special that I've
done this is my duty as a Muslim to
protect our people so if anything I
would like everybody to please pray for
me pray for my family and just remember
me my family in the earth was just
Alcala so hurt for yourself that he was
a witness to English things were
witnessed and this is exactly what's
happened and some people some people
would actually believe that he slipped
up 19 managed to hit hold on to the
sister whether it may be in Charlotte
raise awareness inshallah and let's
educate people rather than sisters you
might turn a blind out you might be true
B's you know I'm making my money you
know I've got a business I've got a nice
car my family's safe Brava if you do not
do something about it however it may be
by educating these people it's gonna be
your sister Nicks I have no doubt this
is gonna be your mother your daughter
your wife or your sister don't brush it
support organizations who are in the
front line it doesn't have to be
whoever it may be I are handling another
beautiful example doing amazing work
around the world support them and stuff
I love organizations you don't want to
do the work you're busy we are ready to
do it we're at the front line and
hamdulillah we just need the resources
and hamdullah we have all the resources
just carry on supporting our work
inshaallah so we can tackle these issues
and put an end to this madness till next
time
assalamu alaikum warahmatullah better
care to do share this with your friends
and family